we stand with our colleagues in
condemning the bay behaviour
they and the police experienced
while i do not comment in detail on
security matters on the floor of the
chamber
steps must be in place to keep pass
holders secure as they enter and leave
the parliamentary estate
i have requested a situation report from
the metropolitan police via our security
team on how this incident occurred
i understand that arrests have been made
following yesterday's incident and so it
would be appropriate to not confident in
detail
i know it's been reported that some
abuse was direct to the right and rule
member the leader of the opposition
yesterday related to claims made by the
prime minister in this chamber
but regardless of yesterday's incident
i made it clear last week that while the
prime minister's words were not
disorderly they were inappropriate as i
said then these sorts of comments only
inflame opinions and generate disregard
for the house and it is not acceptable
our words have consequences and we
should always be mindful of that fight